info ou intox donc avec anthony st léger
bonsoir entendement on en parlait il ya
quelques minutes la finlande à gauche a
donc fait savoir aujourd'hui qu'elle
voulait adhérer sans délai à l'otan mais
depuis plus d'une semaine les rumeurs
quand indépendant de chars finlandais à
la frontière avec la russie vont bon
train effectivement à l'instar d'une de
cette publication facebook que l'on va
découvrir ensemble regarder elle date du
4 mai et cette légende d'affirmer donc
il y à un déploiement de tanks
finlandais à la frontière russo marc la
même idée dans ce poste twitter la même
vidéo celle-ci ce post twitter qui a
cumulé plus de 15000 vue qui date du 3
mai on a aussi par exemple cette
publication youtube avec vous le voyez
cette ce titre volontairement accrocheur
l'alertent à la troisième guerre
mondiale alors regardez bien cette vidéo
on y voit quoi chaque fois donc ce
convoi ferroviaire assez long qui
transportent des chats qui passe sur un
pont qui traverse une ville dans la
foulée vous avez le démenti de l'armée
finlandaise qui évoque dans un tweet du
4 mai donc très rapidement un exercice
militaire haro 22 exercice qui se
déroule au vous le voyez à nice à l'eau
etc qui l'a alors je ne suis absolument
pas sûr de la prononciation et vous
allez pas me corriger chance chez sûr et
on apprend que cet exercice militaire a
lieu jusqu'à demain sur c'est ce qu'on
apprend sur le site de l'armée
finlandaise un exercice conjoint entre
la finlande évidemment le royaume uni la
lettonie les états unis et l'estonie et
ces informations se confirment quand on
analyse la vidéo effectivement lorsque
vous tapez tour et finlande en anglais
vous tombez sur des images de la tour
neething là là encore je ne garantis
rien une tour qui se trouvent ici à
tempérer donc c'est à l'ouest de la
finlande lorsque vous rend chez alors
s'est tous regardés elle ressemble
vaguement à celle que l'on peut voir
dans la vidéo alors cette tour en
question lorsque vous recherchez sur
google earth cette fois vous retrouvez
effectivement l'endroit où a été tournée
la vidéo
c'est à dire à proximité du parc turn
donne on reconnaît vous le voyez donc le
pont ferroviaire la tour évidemment la
végétation alentour
également l'immeuble blanc et gris je
vous ai fait un petit comparatif ici
avec différents cadres de couleurs quant
aux mouvements de train on se souvient
que dans la vidéo il allait de
l'immeuble regarder vers la tour et en
l'occurrence d'est en ouest et non pas l
inverse son petit s'éloignait de la
frontière russe et non pas se dirigea
vers elle merci anthony pour ces
éclaircissements direction maintenant
les philippines ferdinand marcos junior
le fils du dictateur éponyme a remporté
la présidentielle du 9 mai mais lors
d'une soirée électorale des images
truquées de résultats ont circulé
effectivement deux captures d'écran la
première c'est celle ci elle concerne
des résultats qu aurait affiché la
chaîne de télé philippines 10mn news
selon la publication que l'on voit ici
la candidate lenny robredo en deuxième
position derrière donc ferdinand marcos
junior enregistrerait vous le voyez un
nombre proche de voix proche alors que
les résultats officiels
au même moment donné au fils du
dictateur une large avance là vous voyez
qu'ils sont à 19 millions contre 20
millions c'est très serré on note
regardez ici leur 21h 9h25 heure locale
si vous regardez le direct de la chaîne
en question qui a publié donc ce direct
vous voyez que lénine roberto n'est
absolument pas à 19 millions de votes
mais plutôt à 9 millions 5 quasiment 19
et 19 27 contre dans la publication à
virale face à cette contrefaçon la
chaîne a même dû publier sur son compte
twitter un démenti voilà donc le
décompte publié à ce moment là pour
rappel 9 millions et non pas 19,1
millions une large avance donc pour
marcos contrairement à ce qui était
indiqué et une autre publication
trompeuse affirme elle aussi que les nih
rodrigo a plus de voix qu'en réalité
effectivement regarder cette fois c'est
des résultats que corey montrer le média
nbc si bienne près de 18 3 millions de
voix pour les nids robredo plus de 21,7
pour marcos junior faux a rétorqué tout
de suite le 10 mai
le média en question habib sy est si
bien news là encore sur son compte
twitter en dénonçant à des manipulations
et cette supercherie mais alors d'où
vient cette capture d'écran et bien elle
vient de ce site à lalanne louise hunt
le même qui a été mise en place par le
média nbc si bienne sauf que ce site
présente une faille regarder lorsque
vous sélectionnez par exemple un chiffre
qui vous intéresse on va prendre le
nombre de voix pour ferdinand marcos
junior que vous faites un clic droit
comme je lé fais ici sur inspecté vous
cliquez sur inspecté une page va
s'ouvrir ici sur la droite et figurez
vous que vous allez pouvoir je vais
grossir
corriger le chiffre en question et c'est
ce que je me suis amusé à faire regarder
j'ai donné 60 millions de voix pour
ferdinand un marcos il vous suffit
ensuite de fermer la page à droite de
faire une capture d'écran et de la
publier sur des réseaux sociaux un jeu
d'enfant donc alors c'est un fox elles
s'inscrivent dans la lignée de tout ce
qu'on a pu voir pendant la campagne une
véritable campagne de désinformation
alors pour le coup plutôt en faveur de
marques au sein il y avait tant taux des
récits qui glorifiait lui et son père 20
l'héritage de son père plus exactement
le média rapeller par exemple sont fait
l'écho ici en rappelant on s'en souvient
ça a été confondu par maria ray ça que
l'on voit ici un prix nobel de la paix
il y avait aussi des attaques plus
générale mensongères et des campagnes de
dénigrement envers la rivale lenny
robredo arrivait donc en deuxième
position merci beaucoup andry pour cette
chronique est un point tox passionnant